hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar Canada Oris strategies for
preventing an outbreak i'm susie valdez
of lab routes and I'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by Diaz Zorn molecular to learn more
about our sponsor please visit them at
molecular dot dia Soren comm so let's
get started before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send all the questions
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration after the
presentation is over if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits I now present today's
speaker dr. oh my Garner an associate
clinical professor and section chief in
the department of pathology and
laboratory medicine at UCLA health
system for a complete biography on our
speaker please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen welcome dr.
garner you may now begin your
presentation thank you Susie so I'd like
to begin by thanking lab roots and dia
Sauron for hosting this seminar you know
I think that this is a very important
topic not only to clinical laboratories
but also to hospitals infection
prevention areas nursing homes really
anywhere where you could find this
particular pathogen so as soon as you
mentioned the talk today is called
Canada Oris strata
jeez for preventing an outbreak
so to begin with some Ducote disclosures
I have research funding in my laboratory
from relevantly be mru Dias Oran
molecular and Beckman Coulter and then I
have taken an honorarium for speaking
from Dias or molecular so I really want
to begin with this super bug so as you
can see from these headlines we've
really had a lot of press around Canada
Oris and just to read these so from
health a deadly superbugs fungus called
Canada aureus has been detected in 12
states here's what you need to know this
drug-resistant fungus is spreading
scientists warn of new superbugs to come
and this super bug is a serious global
health threat here's what you need to
know about Canada Oris you know I think
that this is this is unusual this is not
how we have handled overall outbreaks in
the past and I really think that it
speaks to not only the seriousness of
this infection but also our global
understanding of outbreaks and how we
can come together even as a public to
fight these types of diseases
so we have three objectives for the talk
today after the talk today I would hope
that the audience would it be able to
discuss the spread of Canada Oris
through a healthcare system described
how microbiology laboratories can assist
in limiting Canada Oris infections and
this is going to be a big part of this
talk you know I really want to take away
to be that folks working in a clinical
microbiology laboratory are part of
fighting this particular outbreak and
then the audience should be able to
detail the challenges and accurately
identify in Canada Oris from culture
within the laboratory space so as an
outline of the talk today we're going to
start with a clinical case a clinical
case that really highlights the deadly
nature of this super bug and then move
on to a hospital associated case so
figuring out an understanding on how
this bug moves around the hospital and
really can put patients in danger then
we'll move on to detailing the global
spread of this organism since 2009 then
I'm going to move into the microbiology
and really talk about an introduction to
the organism talk about how we identify
the organism what it looks like on the
plate what susceptibility testing
results look like for Canada Oris and
then what the microbiology laboratory
can do to help stem this global outbreak
and this is going to include concepts of
passive surveillance or things that's
going to be done in the laboratory or
active surveillance which is really key
around how you can appropriately screen
patients who are colonized for this
organism
so let's start with the clinical case so
this case is published the reference is
on the bottom of the screen a 63 year
old man presents to a Malaysian hospital
with abdominal pain weight loss and
fever his complete blood cell count
shows pancytopenia
including leukopenia and neutropenia he
started on IV antibiotics and he has
blood cultures drawn all this normal
through a potential sepsis workout day 1
and day 4 blood cultures are negative
but the day nine blood culture is
positive by Gram stain from the bottle
and reveals yeasts like cells so this is
really the first clue for the clinicians
involved in this case that potentially
there's a yeast causing this disease and
so at that point they start IV
fluconazole IV fluconazole is a normal
treatment for yeast identification in
the blood because typically the number
one yeast causing Canidae mia is canada
albicans and canada albicans can be seen
as predictably susceptible to
fluconazole so in this case they're
guessing it's potentially Candida
albicans and putting fluconazole on
board unfortunately despite antifungal
treatment the clinical condition
deteriorated by day 15 because the
patient was getting worse they added me
rope enim meropenem is added to be able
to cover potential unusual gram
negatives or resistant gram negatives
that could be causing infection by day
16 the patient showed a brain bleed but
surgical intervention was impossible due
to the low platelets so they couldn't
relieve that pressure or that bleeding
and then by day 18 unfortunately the
patient had passed away
so I want to dive into the
microbiological workup of this
particular case because an organism
identification didn't come about through
this clinical case that could have led
to different treatment so looking at the
microbiology workup on day nine you'll
remember the blood culture bottle was
yeast positive on the Gram stain they
subculture that blood culture bottle to
Saburo dextrose plate this is a plate
specifically to grow yeast or fungus and
after 48 hours a yeast lake colony group
now at this point because the laboratory
itself wasn't able to do full yeast
identification and fungal workup they
sent the plate out to a reference
laboratory for further organism
identification and I think that this is
common practice in a lot of microbiology
laboratories the ability to do East
identification on hand isn't something
that all labs can do but most labs have
some kind of send out lab they could
move the isolate to for identification
unfortunately when that happens though
you see delays in overall organism
identification so at this point at the
reference laboratory 48 hours later a
cream-colored smooth East colony was
growing on this sab dextrose plate and
it only appeared to be one morpha type
so it appears there was only one type of
yeast there this was also plated onto
chromogenic agar the chrome agar
specifically can identify different
species of canada by the color that they
show up with and what was interesting in
this case is that even though on the SD
a it appeared there was only one type of
Canada there on the chrome agar there
were two different colors and so you can
see this represented by picture so an a
there was one I slit showing up greenish
on the chrome agar they labeled uz one
four four six and then there was isolate
be showing up pink or pinkish mob on the
chrome agar I slit using one four four
seven and they held that second isolate
for 120 hours and you can see it
developed this purple color on the
chrome agar so this was really
necessitating a workup of two different
yeasts that
found in the blood so one of the initial
workups is just to look at the colonies
specifically under the microscope so
they isolated yeast cells and what they
saw in either colony was small budding
yeasts
you can see this on a and B and then
there are multiple identification
schemes to be able to figure out what
type of yeast it is and to identify that
type of yeast two species one of the
things that you can do is you can grow
the organism on cornmeal agar and look
for pseudo Highfill formation specific
types of pseudo Highfill formation can
lead to a potential identification of
the organism so isolate you see one four
four six on corn meal after 48 hours
showed long branched pseudo high speed
but isolate using one four four seven
after 48 hours on corn meal no
pseudohyphae was observed being able to
put these yeast in categories for
identification
they also proceeded with identification
systems within that laboratory to
identify so some of these were
biochemical or carbohydrate based so
looking at the first isolate this uz one
four four six you can see that the API
twenty C called it Canada tropicalis at
99%
the vitek - which is another yeast
identification also called a candida
tropicalis at 99% this fit in well with
what was seen on the cornmeal Quetta
tropicalis is known to produce those
long pseudo hyphy all this match for an
ID the other organism was a bit
confusing though so the other organism
remember no pseudo high C the API twenty
C called it 99% rotatory Allah glutinous
now this ends up being a little bit of a
problem so I have a picture on the
bottom of what rotatory Allah looks like
on the plate it's a red colored yeast
and if you'll remember the yeast that
was identified uz1 four four seven i
give an example of that plate below
it's a cream-colored so right away this
is leading to questions in the potential
identification another system was run
the Vitek - and it called it canada he
Maloney I so Canada he Maloney I matches
a little bit better with what was seen
from the picture on the yeast but now
you have a distinct discrepancy between
two identification system and so later
in the process so all of that took about
four days as you can see on the right
side but we still don't have a good
identification so they moved to
sequencing and so in moving to
sequencing what they found is that an
IPS sequencing it confirmed the Canada
tropicalis but what was revealed about
uz1 447 was that this I slit was
actually a Canada torus and this was
also confirmed by a different sequencing
method
moving on to susceptibility testing what
was found that when you did
susceptibility testing of the Canada
tropicalis what you saw is that whether
it's amphotericin tasco pungent and
ninja of plunge in any Lea kind of
Camden's or all of the assaults
Buchanan's all it reconnaissance all
they all tested as susceptible so the
blue-collar sought treatment that the
patient was put on when the Gram stain
revealed yeast in the blood would have
covered this particular organism the
problem is that when that testing was
performed on Canada Wars and later on
we'll get into the talk about
susceptibility testing for Canada Oris
what was found is that the Canada Oris
was resistant to all of the animals but
also especially resistant to the
antifungal that the patient was placed
upon which was fluconazole so this ended
up being a fatal case of Canada Oris in
mixed Canada Mia with Canada tropicalis
in a neutropenia patient just showing
how deadly this bug is and how resistant
it can be to antifungals that are put on
board
so I want to take a step back then and
talk about the global emergence of this
infection Canada Oris was first isolated
from ear discharged in 2009 in Japan and
at that time it was a very difficult
organism to identify then a study from
South Korea identified 15 patients with
Canada Oris otitis media in 2009 and you
can see either ear infections or ear
discharge this is where this Canada gets
its name that's why it's called Canada
Oris interesting though in that same
year there were no psycho meal or
hospital-associated infections reported
in South Korea then over time the
organism has continued to spread around
the globe from 2012 to 2019 and so I
have a picture of global map in current
opinion of microbiology published in
2019 showing that in 2009 you really
only saw Canada Waris infection in Japan
in South Korea but over time 2013 2016
2018 we saw this distinct spread of this
organism globally
so how is that happening you know how is
an organism spreading so dramatically
around the globe and I think that
highlighting how it spreads through a
hospital system can show how it spread
as infected patients move their way
around the world so we're going to use
an example from the UK so there was an
initial case of Canada Oris that was
reported at the Royal Brompton Hospital
in London and this is a 20 bed in there
20 bed adult ICU facility the following
week the patient in the adjacent bed in
that room was found to be Canada or as
positive from a sputum specimen and
developed a line infection subsequently
then nine other cases were identified
and when environmental sampling was done
it showed contamination with Canada Oris
all around the room there were similar
patterns of introductions and local
spread of the organism that have
reported in the US and around the world
so you can really see that health care
centers end up being areas where an
infected patient can spread this
organism not only to other patients
causing infection but also through the
environment so this brings up the
question of infection and colonization
with this organism I really want to
start with clinical infection so what
typical disease types do we see reported
for Canada Oris infection and this is
from a fantastic clinical microbiology
reviews called Canada or as a review of
the literature in 2017 and what was seen
in this table is that there were 291
reported cases of Canada Mia by Canada
Oris or Canada found in the blood and
this has been the most common site of
infection for Canada ORS but it's also
been associated with other types of
infections so it's been isolated from
central venous catheter tips CNS ear
nose and throat respiratory tract
urogenital system abdominal infections
skin and soft-tissue infections
including surgical wounds and even in
the bone so this organism doesn't just
exclusively cause disease in the blood
but can also cause disseminated and
devastating disease in other areas of
the body
so that what type of patients are
associated with Canada or infections so
they're found most often with invasive
Candida Oris infections and patients who
are critically ill patients who are
found in intensive care patients
undergoing invasive procedures patients
with serious underlying medical
conditions
patients with hematological malignancies
immune suppression broad-spectrum
antibiotics patients with medical
devices like catheter CVC's or your
regional catheters and patients and long
term care facilities including nursing
homes so what's interesting about this
is that this is also the risk factor
group for any invasive Candida
infections and yet the mortality rates
from Canada Oris infections that are
invasive can be up to 50% so higher than
we've seen potentially in other Canada
infections and a lot of that has to do
with the extended resistance we can
contrast infection with colonization and
so there's been a link between patients
with infect invasive infection being
colonized so what area are these
patients colonized with this organism so
Canada Oris has been grown from patients
with invasive infraction from the Nerys
from the groin from the axilla and the
rectum it has also been isolated for up
to three months or more after the
initial infection so it's interesting
there is that even if the infection is
cleared the Canada tourists can still be
colonizing that patient as we saw in the
hospital infection in the UK it can also
be isolated from the environment of
colonized patients and it appears
patients with colonized with Canada Oris
actually successfully shed this organism
into the environment so then it's
interesting to think about contact time
how long would it take for a patient to
shed Canada or us from the environment
and you test for it in the environment
so contact time for acquisition of
Canada horas from a colonized patient or
from the environment has been shown in
as little as four hours so a patient
moving into a room that has
environmental contamination can be
colonized with that or
very quickly and then invasive
infections after that colonization have
been acquired from contaminated areas
within as little as 48 hours of an
admission so a very aggressive organism
in not only its ability to contaminate
the environment but also to colonize a
new patient and cause invasive infection
in that patient
so again this all then contributes to an
unsurprising spread and global spread of
Canada Oris you know we live in a very
connected world you know I think we see
this with a lot of outbreak organisms
we've seen this in our recent ongoing
Ebola outbreaks that people move around
the world and bring infections with them
and so it's not a surprise then with an
organism that is so ubiquitous in either
its ability to colonize or actually live
in the environment that you can see
spread of this organism globally
so I wanted to look then specifically at
some of these outbreaks and how Canada
Oris can become the predominant invasive
infection in an outbreak location so
let's look first specifically at a Spain
outbreak of Canada aureus in 2016 and so
invasive Canada infections were looked
at pre the outbreak and post the
outbreak so before the outbreak what you
saw is that most of the infections
invasive infections were associated with
Candida albicans at 31% Canada perhaps
the losest at 46% and again these
organisms can usually be treated with
fluconazole and then of course there was
Canada glabrata clinic tropicalis
representing a lower percentage but then
after the outbreak and you know this is
I think where this number becomes
shocking 42% of the invasive candidate
Canada infections were associated with
Canada Oris so now again a population in
an organism that can't just be readily
treated with fluconazole so it's almost
like Canada taking over for the invasive
infections after an outbreak which makes
it so important for an area to stop an
outbreak from happening in the first
place
we can also unfortunately see similar
numbers from outbreaks of Canada orison
South Africa so here on the y-axis we're
looking at the number of overall cases
of Canada Mia in South Africa in 2016
and 2017 the number is 29 88 these are
private sector hospitals and you can see
that after their during their outbreak
setting even though perhaps closest was
number one candidate Oris was the number
two cause of Canada Mia in South Africa
making mortality rates grow up making
treatment very very difficult
so I want to then look specifically at
the global spread of Canada Oris looking
at the CDC website and I would just
encourage everyone listening to this the
CDC actually has a wealth of information
on Canada Oris if you have any other
questions after this talk I encourage
you to go to the website and I've tried
to highlight this website as we go
through to learn more about Canada Wars
so this is a map showing the countries
from which Canada aureus cases have been
reported as of August 31st 2019 and so
what you can see even compared to the
other maps that I've shown is that this
organism continues to spread so first
looking at the light green color cases
these are countries where there's a
single Canada aureus case that's been
reported so you see this in Chile you
can see this in Turkey you can see this
in parts of Southeast Asia and what
we've seen before is that these
countries that have one case quickly
progress to countries that have
transmission or multiple cases so the
countries in light blue are the
countries that have had transmission or
multiple cases of Canada or is reported
you can see in North America this
includes the United States and Canada
South America Colombia Venezuela South
Africa many countries in Europe many
countries in Asia in addition because
this is a CDC map it also shows
countries where US Canada or as cases
are linked to healthcare states and so
these are patients that had healthcare
stains in different countries came back
to the United States brought Canada Oris
back and continued outbreak infections
in these areas and you can see that
includes Colombia South Africa India
many countries have contributed so it
just kind of shows how this global
spread is continuing
I want to take a deeper dive then into
infections in the United States and so
this is a US map of clinical cases of
Canada Oris reported by US states as of
March 31st 2019 and so you can see there
have been three states that have
reported 100 or more Canada horas
clinical cases this includes New York
New Jersey and Chicago there's a state
that has between 11 to 50 infection this
includes Florida and then moving on down
California Texas Oklahoma have seen
between 2 and 10 clinical cases and then
other states like Indiana and other
states have shown other lower levels of
infection I think what's important to
realize here is that an infectious case
vastly underestimates the number of
colonized patients and what we've seen
in this outbreak is that if you have
someone with Canada Auris in their blood
and you start to do patient surveillance
around that person room surveillance and
hospital surveillance you find many
times that number of patients that have
already been colonized
so looking specifically in detail at
some of the spread in the United States
uh there have been 725 confirmed and 30
probable cases of Canada horas as of
June 30th 2019 but twice that number so
1,400 total patients have been found to
be colonized those colonized patients of
course are now highly at risk for
invasive Canada Oris disease most of
these cases have been associated with
either hospitals or long term care
facilities like nursing homes in New
York City New Jersey and Chicago but as
I mentioned nine other states have
reported outbreaks looking into the
details of one of the New York outbreaks
in 2017
it included a hundred and sixty-six
clinical cases a hundred and eighty-four
colonised patients and they all came
from one source patient one source
identification of canada horas for that
entire outbreak so you can see that this
represents a and I won't even say
potential this represents a public
health emergency and why this could
expand is if we look at that table over
the number of patients we have in our
states that are in registered nursing
homes and so this is from 2017 data it
estimates overall there's six hundred
thousand people in registered nursing
homes and we have a hundred thousand
just in California this represents a
population that if Canada Oris can take
a hold cause an outbreak and colonize in
that area all these patients could
potentially be colonized or infected
so I hope that the last few slides have
sort of highlighted the immediacy of the
issue and why we really need to look
into what we can do to stop the further
spread of Canada Wars so now I want to
spend the next few slides introducing
you to the microbiology of this very
interesting organism so Canada Oris as
we saw on the clinical case grows as a
nondescript white to cream-colored
colony on SDA these pictures are
pictures that came from the cdc website
and so that's the top picture and the
bottom picture pink to beige color
colony on chroma genic agar or chrome
agar what's interesting about the
nondescript white to cream-colored
colony is that that is what most candid
does look like when they grow up on a
plate so it's an initial growth it's not
a clue to whether or not it's Canada or
its ovoid
to elongated budding yeast cells on
cornmeal agar without the formation of
pseudo high P in most cases and it grows
well at both 37 and 42 degrees it's
interesting to look at the genome so it
has a haploid 12.5 mega base genome with
between 65 hundred and eighty 500
protein coding sequences and when an
analysis of those sequences that duck is
done there are many genes associated
with virulence so the ability for this
organism to cause invasive infection and
then there are also genes for biofilm
formation both in a patient but also in
the environment and I think this shows
why this organism a could be so invasive
but also has the tools to colonize the
environment genomically its most closely
related to Canada Lusitania and Canada
he Maloney I this becomes a large
problem for laboratories because these
are two of the identifications that are
most often misidentified as Canada or or
Canada Wars is misidentified as these
two organisms so it's divided up into
Geographic clade South Asian South
African South American East Asian and
most u.s. isolates are mainly from the
South Asian and South American plates
so I want to dive in specifically in the
lab identification you know I think that
we saw from the clinical case there was
a misidentification as rotatory Ola but
we knew it wasn't pink there was also a
misidentification as Canada he Maloney I
and these are very very tricky for a lab
to be able to work out and it's
critically important for a lab to know
whether or not they have Canada oars and
so this is an old table so this is the
review from 2017 we're going to talk
about the updated identification schemes
but you can see whether it's API or
Phoenix or Vitek or micro scan even some
of the maldito phytic a massive multi
biotype er previous two updates were not
able to reliably call canada or us in
fact for most of these systems canada
Oris wasn't even in the database so
ultimately the identification could be
an unidentified Canada where it would
miss identify it as a different Candida
species
now the CDC actually has an excellent
PDF around different identification
schemes and their ideality to identify
canada horas reliably and i want to show
off a couple of these four systems that
have been used in the UCLA system so
starting with the Vitek - yeast
so the Vitek - yeast card if you go down
the right side of the pathway the older
versions identify Canada Oris as either
Canada he Maloney i candida dual bus he
Maloney I or Canada species not
identified and if you don't have the
current software version update of that
any time one of those isolates comes off
Canada aureus is actually a possibility
and at that point it's going to require
further workup by the laboratory to rule
out Canada Oris now recently Vitek came
out with a software upgrade and that
software upgrade actually allowed it to
identify Canada or so going down the
left side of the pathway now you can see
that Canada Oris can be confirmed if
Canada aureus is confirmed on the vitek
with the software upgrade you can see
that the recommendations are to place
the patient in transmission based
precautions report to the CDC and notify
state and local health departments those
systems can still miss identify Canada
Loras as he Maloney I do about tmaloney
I or Canada species not identified so
even in those cases you do need to do
further workup and if Canada Oris is
possible they suggest sending isolates
to a reference laboratory a state public
health lab a regional lab or the CDC for
further identification and to place the
patient in transmission based
precautions until that rule out is
confirmed now at the UCLA microbiology
laboratory we use the VMware you Vitek
MS maldito for organism identification
of yeast starting on the right side of
the pathway for older IBD libraries so
these are libraries before the most
current IBD library update you can see
that Canada Wars didn't exist in the
system so because of that whether it's
Canada hemo
only I Canada Lusitania or no
identification
all of these required further workup but
once the new update came through Canada
Oris can be reliably identified and
confirmed and with the vitac ms and this
is true of the other multi talk systems
as well it's no longer going to miss
identify that organism as he Maloney I
or Lusitania so ahem ellonija of who
Maloney I or Lusitania a call on that
system can now be reliable
so no matter what system that you use
and ultimately cut off what clinical
microbiology laboratories use a wide
variety of identification systems the
CDC has this great reference that I
suggest you all download to be able to
look at your own individual system and
see whether or not that system can
confirm Canada or s identification or if
not what sort of follow-up testing is
necessary and you can see most of the
identification systems are listed here
what's interesting is there are some
phenotypic notes on the bottom so let's
say for example we look at the micro
scale system the Microscan system is not
yet set up to identify Canada or us but
if it highlights your Mon di / abyssal
OSIS Lusitania there's a note on the
bottom that says these organisms
generally make high fee or pseudohyphae
on corn meal going back to the
experiment we saw with the case if Heidi
or pseudohyphae are not present the
isolate should raise suspicion as being
Candida or so again more of a workflow
however some Canada Oris isolates have
formed high PR pseudo high C so again
all this is requiring reference labs
send out for identification for these
particular systems
so it's interesting if you have a system
in house that goes through one of the
upgrades to be able to identify Canada
Oris the laboratory needs to verify that
identification so it isn't enough that
the system says it can do it now you as
a laboratory need to test whether or not
that's true
so we at UCLA recently upgraded our
software to IVD library version 3.2 for
BMR you and our vitek ms and this
includes canada horas so I went under
walk labs through the process of how we
then test for verification of this we
did an accuracy test we contacted the
CDC and into CDC's AR bank or
antimicrobial resistance Bank of
organism they actually can send you a
set of organisms that you can test so
they sent us 11 different Canada Oris
and then other isolates that are
commonly misidentified that Canada is
commonly misidentified as so 3 Canada
dual boesky Maloney I to Canada he
Maloney I a couple of Saccharomyces
cerevisiae a Kota male Mary a Canada
cruzi and a Canada Lusitania and when we
did this testing we found a hundred
percent of these isolates were
identified correctly on the Vitek ms
what was also important for us to verify
was different types of media
so as fungal cultures come into our
laboratory they can get plated out on
different things and that plating can
lead to different levels of accuracy on
your Vitek so we tested species level
identification on inhibitory mold agar
we tested it on sab decks or sab high so
our brain heart infusion agar and then
we did some precision testing which was
three isolates tested for three days and
quadruplets all of this passed giving us
the sign off confidence that if we have
a Canada Loris will be able to recognize
it two species in our laboratory
so I want to spend a couple of minutes
talking about susceptibility testing and
interpretation so what we found in the
clinical case is the Canada tourists had
to be identified correctly the species
but was also resistant to a lot of the
known antifungals so Canada Oris has
shown multidrug-resistant it is probably
a higher level of multi-drug resistance
that we see in any other candidate
species some isolates have demonstrated
elevated minimum inhibitory
concentrations to all available
antifungal drug classes and this
includes Hazel's amphotericin and the
kind of candidates so breaking out the
isolates over 90% of the isolates have a
high mi CSD fluconazole so you can
generally think of Canada Oris as being
resistant to flick-on us all thus
fluconazole treatment without knowing
the identification can lead to dangerous
situations with Canada Oris infections
30% will be resistant to amputation 40%
of the iceland's are resistant to two or
more drug classes and 10% are resistant
to all antifungals only 5% are just
resistant they kind of candid so in that
setup you know I think that treatment
changes before you identify whether or
not the identical species identification
of the yeast has been moving from
something like a nasal - in areas of
high Canada or something like in a kind
of candid where there's a lower chance
of resistance interestingly antifungal
susceptibility testing for Canada Oris
is not standardized clsi has not put out
full canada tourist break points and so
when looking at a table here and this
comes from a journal of clinical
microbiology paper in 2018 Canada orison
emerging fungal pathogen we can look at
some of the m.i.c ranges and they have a
list of potential resistant break points
so for fluconazole the idea of a
potential resistant break point is
greater than 32 the m.i.c range of all
organisms for Canada Wars test it was
0.12 - greater than 64 but an mi see 50
and this is an mi see that allows for
killing of 50% or
Eider of the organism was all the way up
at greater than 64 so this shows that
this organism is almost routinely highly
resistant to fluconazole we see some
variation in some of the other a it
solves the Econo cannons including a
ninja dungeon and cash flow function and
then also anthat Arison and so the m.i.c
ranges are abroad but we can definitely
see resistance to those antifungals as
well
so all of this paints a fairly
disturbing picture right we have an
organism that can cause invasive disease
contaminate the environment is very
difficult for the laboratory to quickly
identify as Canada horas and
susceptibility testing is not routine
and doesn't have good break points so
what can we then do as a microbiology
laboratory to help stop this outbreak so
number one you want to be able to ensure
that your lab uses a yeast
identification system that can
accurately identify Canada ores from a
clinical sample or knows where its own
identification system is weak so it
knows when to send an isolate out the
key part of all of this is this is
really a race against time right once a
Canada organism is isolated and
identified the longer it takes to
identify it two species the more likely
that that Canada torus can be passed
around the hospital the more likely that
invasive infections can occur and as you
saw before sometimes it only takes 48
hours to be able to have a patient get
colonized and have an invasive infection
from a Canada tourist in the environment
so we need to work as laboratories to be
able to identify these organisms
accurately to species as quickly as
possible in doing that you want to be
sure you perform a laboratory
verification to make sure the system is
both accurate and precise and you want
to make sure yeast susceptibility
testing is available for clinically
relevant isolates this can either be in
house which is more unusual we do
in-house testing at UCLA for Canada or
as a send out to support clinical
treatment this really helps in the case
of identification as well so if you have
a Canada that couldn't be identified to
species but you're able to do some
susceptibility testing potentially you
can guide therapy before that full
species identification comes through
so another thing a laboratory can do is
called passive surveillance and this is
an idea of how do we for any yeast
within the clinical microbiology
laboratory try and identify Canada Oris
so I would say many or most clinical
microbiology laboratories only identify
yeast to species from sterile sites
blood tissue CSF but in non sterile
sites genital urine through but usually
only identified as yeast on the lab
report and this is enough to help with
clinical treatment the challenge here is
that this allows for a potential missing
of a Canada aureus infection and so
state and County Public Health
laboratories are suggesting that
clinical microbiology laboratory start
attempting to identify these organisms
to the species level especially for
inpatients
what we found in the outbreak in Orange
County is that it was this level of
passive surveillance and the
identification of a yeast species as
Canada Oris in the urine which led to
understanding that there was an outbreak
going on so we recognized though that
this is a significant impact on workflow
for a potential mycology branch bench so
at UCLA we're identifying two species
all yeasts that are ordered as fungal
culture but if the yeast grows up on a
bacterial culture which can routinely
happen especially in things like urine
or respiratory we would either identify
that as yeast or if it was low enough
quantity it's just part of normal flora
in moving forward with passive
surveillance it's not that we're going
to identify that yeast to species if
it's not Canada or us for clinical care
but what we want to be able to do is
test all of them to rule out Canada Oris
so at UCLA there are about 2600 cultures
positive cultures over the last six
months that fit into that particular
category and of that 200 of them had a
yeast reported so this is really a
movement of 400 additional yeast
identifications onto a mycology bench we
are a medium-sized academic center in
clinical microbiology laboratory we
recognize
eyes that these sorts of suggestions may
be very very difficult to follow up on
in the large reference centers that have
much many more cultures but we do agree
that this is one way to monitor your
patient population to see whether or not
Canada Oris is in your hospital
another thing that the lab can
participate in is something called
active surveillance an active
surveillance is really this notion of
screening patients for colonization on a
mission to a hospital
what high-risk patients can you look at
coming in to know whether or not they
have Canada or us and put in the
appropriate infection prevention
measures to be able to stop that from
being moved around your hospital
so there are CDC guidelines to this on
who should be screened for Canada ORS so
TC guidelines dictate closed healthcare
contacts of patients with newly
identified Canada Oris infection or
colonization including roommates at
nursing homes additionally patients who
have had an overnight stay in healthcare
facilities outside of the United States
in the previous year where there have
been documented cases of Canada horas as
you can see by the list below that is a
lot of different countries now this ends
up being challenging for a hospital
being able to recognize on intake
whether or not one of these two things
have occurred but if they can recognize
them surveillance is suggested so how is
active surveillance occur how do you
figure out whether or not someone is
colonized with Canada wars so the
suggestion from the CDC is to screen
with a single composite swab of the
bilateral axilla and groin and this is
called a Zorro swab or AZ swab and you
can see it goes across the armpits and
over the groin these are the most common
and consistent sites of colonization and
these have been used as sort of
screening has been used in the outbreaks
in New York and the outbreaks in Chicago
to be able to recognize colonized
patients
the question that is how then do you
figure out whether there's any Canada
Waris in that specimen that was taken so
right now screening by culture based
methods are available as a send out to
the a our lab network so the air lab
network is a series of labs in the lrn
so on the west coast
our laboratory of the Washington State
Public Health lab and in this setting if
they're screening of a high-risk patient
you can send that sample the Washington
State you submit the e swabs on ice
within 96 hours of collection and they
will culture to be able to figure out
whether there's any candidate orison
there this is a fantastic service and is
available to any clinical laboratories
within that region part of the challenge
of the service though is that it's a 1
to 3 week turnaround time culture
methods take a long time and from an
infection prevention standpoint if
you're going to have a patient in
isolation for two to three weeks before
they figure out whether they have Canada
Oris that's ok for one patient but that
may extend even beyond their stay in the
hospital and if you have 40 patients
that now need to be screened you may not
be able to keep that many patients
within isolation or cohort them together
because you don't know which one as
Canada Wars which one doesn't have
scanner wars so this represents a
challenge for both hospitals and
clinical laboratories you can screen by
culture for Canada or as in house and so
as a microbiology laboratory not send
out but current culture surveillance
recommendations include inoculation on
the several selective agar plates and
enrichment broth to be able to increase
sensitivity once those are done you
still need to hold the culture for up to
two weeks to actually rule out a
negative unfortunate culture in and of
itself it's an extended workup it's
difficult for laboratories to perform
and we think that the length of culture
time is suboptimal for surveillance and
infection control efforts
so we feel there's an urgent need for a
clinical PCR test for surveillance
Canada or s that can be rapidly
implemented in many clinical
microbiology laboratories and we've been
working on developing that here at UCLA
so we've recently developed and are
using a Canada or surveillance PCR that
offers a rapid turnaround time so the
test can provide in four hours
test results on 12 samples and the
ability to include up to 94 samples in
Iran which is advantageous in a
healthcare setting when high-volume
surveillance is needed I want to go into
some of the details on the development
of this particular test and so in
targeting the PCR the PCR assay itself
targets a highly conserved region of the
I TS to gene in canada Oris and this PCR
assay target the primer targets were
tested for cross reactivity against a
number of different organisms so almost
all the Canada and thus ends up being
super important because Canada is an
organism were all colonized with right
as part of our normal microbial flora
and you don't want a false positive
Canada Oris just because Canada albicans
is there other species as well other
molds other bacteria even other viruses
just to look for cross reactivity and
there was no cross reactivity that was
seen then in that setting we needed to
put together a PCR protocol and so we
put together a protocol not only for
colony suspension from culture but also
from the east swab that will be taken
directly from the patient briefly just
to go over this we resuspend a pelleted
east swab in point five mils of lysis
buffer transfer that do both bead
beading vortexing and heating and all
these steps actually are critically
important in being able to get a
sensitive pcr assay the candidate cell
wall is a tough component and if you
don't break that cell wall open and
reveal all the nucleic acid that's there
it can greatly negatively affect the
sensitivity of your assay so we go
through a substantial pre extraction
step and then we extract DNA on a kaijin
platform the easy one DNA platform and
then we have some positive controls and
negative controls of course so Canada or
strain is a positive control negative
control is e swab matrix alone
moving on we worked with Dias Oran to be
able to put this test working on the
liaison MDX platform it's a platform
that we at UCLA have numerous laboratory
developed tests and so in that setting
the assay definitions are there the
cycling parameters are there and we
built out the assay to be able to give
us a sensitive and specific PCR so
really building out the assay is the
first component the next component
is how you have a clinical validation so
understanding whether or not this is
going to work clinically I wanted to
walk the audience through our clinical
validation so we took negative east swab
media and we had a healthy male adult
volunteer living in Los Angeles where at
that time there were no Canada Wars
cases reported who agreed to have his
armpits and groin swab numerous times to
be able to fill out a negative East swab
media so now we have media that we can
spike in Canada horas to I for
identification then we spiked in Canada
or s at burying delusions ranging all
the way from ten colony forming units
very very sensitive all the way up to
ten to the seventh and then in our
negative specimen we were able to spike
in other east yeasts that we knew
potentially cross-react duo buffy
Maloney i he Maloney i Lusitania at a
high concentration and then did a season
recovery so the results are shown in the
table of a hundred and forty one
expected positive Canada tourist by
seeded recovery we had one hundred and
forty one that were positive by PCR of
the eighty four that were negative
containing other organisms all a for
negative by PCR giving a hundred percent
sensitivity and specificity and
concordance across the board another
interesting question is what's the limit
of detection for this so how low can we
potentially go and get usable signal so
spiked samples with serial tempo
dilution of Canada ORS we're testing to
determine the LOD defined as the minimum
concentration with the detection of at
least 95% so the LOD was determined to
be one times ten to the two which brings
us into the range of other LEDs for PCR
s and is very acceptable from a
sensitivity perspective you can see on
the table the mean CT values going all
the way from 17 at one times ten to the
seventh all the way down to 35 and one
times ten to the two giving us a hundred
percent detection rate above ten ten to
the two and above
we also needed to do some precision
testing that precision testing went
relatively quickly so we tested at the
LOD and then also at a high
concentration and you can see there was
a hundred percent detection across the
board and then we wanted to do some
stability how long could it last in a
specimen before we tested and the
stability was constant across the board
we actually even saw some organism
growth at room temperature and so that
led us to the conclusion that we have
successfully developed and validated a
clinical PCR test the laboratory
developed tests showed excellent
performance and we hope that since the
reagents and instruments described in
this validation are commercially
available as a SRS for ldt development
and widely use many other clinical
microbiology laboratories could take
optic dis on use our validation protocol
and then bring in their own in-house PCR
and so to wrap things up in conclusion
you know I take this from a news article
for things in or about Canada Oris
it's a drug-resistant fungus it's
difficult to diagnose it shows outbreaks
and hospitals and nursing homes and it's
preying on elderly patients patients
that are immune compromised clinical
microbiology laboratories are critical
in the fight against Canada Oris and
labs need to be able to use a fungal
identification system that can
accurately identify Canada orestes
species this is important for invasive
infection but also colonization and labs
can practice both passive and active
surveillance to assist in hospital
infection prevention and recognizing
colonized patients a lot of work went
into this I want to thank the UCLA
clinical microbiology laboratory I want
to thank the UCLA infection prevention
team I want to specifically thank Sean
yang Evan Hill
Travis Price Brian Bolland Andrew Mears
all who were specifically involved in
the clinical validation in the forming
of the PCR tests and I also want to
thank the group Adeus or molecular that
assisted and I at this time am open to
any questions
Thank You dr. garner for that
presentation a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into the drop down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window labeled ask a
question and then click on the send
button dr. garner will answer as many
questions as time permits so let's take
a look at our audience questions coming
in dr. Bronner since we know that
Candida
Oris can survive on surfaces do you have
any suggestions for sampling surfaces
and what steps would you suggest for
those facilities that have colonized
patients with active infections as it
relates to ensuring that they have ruled
out surface contamination this is a
great question and so what I didn't
mention in the validation of the PCR
because it was beyond the clinical work
is we actually it validated that PCR for
environmental testing as well and so
what we see in our system is that you
can swab areas of a hospital room get
the bedrail the vitals the floor around
the patient put that into the east swab
media the same east swab media that
we're using for active surveillance and
PCR positivity can be obtained from that
so PCR represents a really good way to
real-time look at environmental
contamination in a room culture of that
is very difficult right it's the same
problem we saw before so if you're going
to attempt culture in how so you're
going to send out to one of our
reference one of the state reference lab
to be able to do this it's still going
to be a two or three week turnaround
time for surveillance so I think
ultimately PCR is the best way to go for
environmental surveillance if a
laboratory is able to do it or if a
local Public Health Laboratory is able
to bring on a PCR test
thank you and since Candida Oris can be
shed by colonized patients and health
work health care workers which allows
the opportunity to contaminate Hospital
environmental services
well infection control practitioners
target both colonized patients and
contaminated surfaces as part of their
infection control measures the answer
that is absolutely yes and so if a
patient is going to be positive the
patient themselves is going to be tested
the room around that patient is going to
be tested both before cleaning and after
cleaning to be able to make sure that
not only is the infection cleared from
the patient but also whether that
patient is continued to be colonized and
whether or not the room itself is
contaminated
thank you and I want to thank our
audience members for these great
questions coming in dr. garner our next
question is when did you complete
validation of your active surveillance
PTR and have you detected a positive
case
so that's another great question so we
completed validation about a month ago
and went live with our test and we
actually have had transfer of a patient
who has known Canada or is positive to
our facility from the Orange County
outbreak and we were able to then
validate not only our surveillance swab
on a patient but also environmental
testing from that particular patient so
we have had a colonized patient at our
facility that was being watched by
infection prevention a known colonized
patient
thank you and once a positive is
detected by the PCR what are the next
steps at your institution and how is the
patient then treated that's a great
question so our patient wasn't it wasn't
from an infection and so it wasn't from
a clinical specimen so in that setting
because the patient was colonized it's
really one getting that patient into an
isolated room we're fortunate enough at
UCLA that all of our rooms are single
occupancy rooms but if they weren't then
that patient would have been needed to
move from a room where they were
cohorted to an isolated room I think
that's the first step and then the
second step is really after clinical
care
so once the patient is treated for
whatever they're there for once they
leave it's a process of surveilling the
room to see whether or not it's
contaminated cleaning the room and then
testing the room again to make sure that
that organism isn't there for the next
patient to come into the room
thank you for that and we have a time
for a couple more questions
does the dear Sauron um primer pair
detect all of the clades
of cannabis can it comes our Canada Oris
yeah that's a great question sue so the
dis or it does it recognizes all the
planes but it doesn't differentiate them
so they would all show up equally Canada
or s+ but for differentiation it really
requires whole genome sequencing and
that's something that is typically
beyond the scope of clinical laboratory
but often can be done in a public health
laboratory for epidemiology and
understanding where the organism where
the outbreak came from
thank you and dr. garner we have time
for one more question
our audience member wants to know can
the PCR test be used for both passive
and active surveillance yeah I think
that's a great question I think that in
general the answer is yes so what you
could do is grow your yeast let's say
the yeast you identify on a urine
culture that you're just going to call
yeast and you could run PCR on that the
challenge in using it that way though is
that's an expensive way to use the test
so ultimately because you already have a
colony there are other cheaper
identification systems especially MALDI
toff that can reliably identify that
organism to species and you can just
keep PCR for the non-culture method so
for surveillance active surveillance and
then also surveillance of the
environment I think that it would be
more cost-effective to use it that way
but ultimately the PCR would also work
on isolated colonies of organisms
thank you and dr. garner do you have any
closing remarks that you'd like to
provide for the audience today uh you
know I just want to empower microbiology
laboratories and laboratory ins to be
involved you know we are a critical part
of not only lab medicine but also
stemming outbreaks diagnose helping to
diagnose infectious disease and
laboratories bringing themselves to the
place where they can confidently
identify Canada orest and assist their
infection prevention really is going to
be one of the major things that stops
this outbreak from proceeding across the
entirety of the United States
well thank you so much for your time
today
dr. garner and thank you for this
important research I'd also like to
thank audience members for joining us
today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today will be addressed by the
speaker via the contact information you
provided at the time of your
registration and I'd like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor the asur and
molecular for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on demand and lab routes will
alert you when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share this email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event until next time bye bye